ففي اول تطور من نوعه نقلت وستري جورنال
عن مسؤولين امريكيين رافعين قولهم ان
الغاره بالمسيرات في ايران نفذتها اسرائيل
واضاف المسؤولون ان استهداف الموقع
العسكري في ايران ياتي في وقت تبحث فيه
واشنطن وتل ابيب طرقا جريده لاحتواء
طموحات طهران نوويه والعسكريه في حين نقلت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن مسؤول عسكريين
امريكيين كبير تاكيده انه لم تقم اي قوه
عسكريه امريكيه بشنها هجمات او عمليات
داخل ايران
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه قد اعلنت
احباط هجوم قالت ان ثلاثه طائرات مسيره
صغيره نفذته مستهدفه مصنعا عسكريا بمحافظه
اصفهان وسط البلاد وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه ان المضادات الدفاعيه تصدت لهذه
المسايرات ما ادى الى انفجار اثنتين منها
وقالت الوزاره ان الاضرار اقتصرت على سقف
المصنع دون الاضرار بالمعدات كما اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه انها ستواصل انتاج
كل ما يلزم لتعزيز قوه وامن البلاد بجديه
وسرعه وان مثل هذه الهجمات العمياء لن
تعوق مسار تطوير البلاد بحسب تعبير
الوزاره
الكلام دوت
الى شبكه مراسلينا من طهران مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز من القدس مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام ومن واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره محمد الاحمد محمد اطلعنا على
تفاصيل اوفى حول ما قالته والسجن
[موسيقى]
كشفت نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين بان
العمليه بان اسرائيل وراء العمليه التي
استهدفت يوم امس مخزن للذخيره بالقرب او
في مدينه اصفهان وهو موقع قريب من وكاله
ابحاث الفضاء الايرانيه وهي وكاله حكوميه
خاضعه للعقوبات الامريكيه بسبب دورها في
تطوير برنامج الاسلحه او الصواريخ
البالستيه الايرانيه هذه اول عمليه معروفه
تحت قياده همم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه في اسرائيل بقياده نتنياهو
نتنياهو كان قد امر بهجمات مماثله عندما
كان رئيس للوراء بين عام
2021 الصحيفه نقلت ايضا عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي او نقلت همم عدم تعليق من
الجيش الاسرائيلي على هذه التقارير وهذه
العمليه لكنها تاتي في الوقت الذي يسعى
فيه الجانب الامريكي والجانب الاسرائيلي
لبلوره سبل من اجل احتواء الانشطه
الايرانيه التي توصف بالمزعزعه للاستقرار
من الناحيه العسكريه وايضا من الناحيه
النوويه وايضا في اطار الرد على انخراط
ايران في الحفيس دعم روسيا في حربها في
اوكرانيا هذه العمليه ايضا جلال تتزامن
وتاتي بعد ايام من زياره لم يعلن عنها
لرئيس السي اي مدير الى اسرائيل وهي
الزياره التي تشير الكثير من التقارير
الاخباريه انها ركز على التهديدات
الايرانيه كما ان الكشف عن هذه العمليه
ياتي بعد مناورات ضخمه بين الجيشين
الامريكي والاسرائيلي قبل ايام شارك فيها
الالاف ودرست سيناريوهات محتمله في اطار
الرد بكل تاكيد على التهديدات الايراني
هذا التطور ياتي ايضا جلال في ظل حاله
جمهور واضحه في مساله المفاوضات النوويه
المت بايران في غياب اي بدائل بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده ووسط تحذيرات متزايده في
الوقت نفسه من تسارع وتيره تطور برنامج
النووي الايراني وايضا الانشطه التي توصف
بانها مزعزعه للاستقرار وبالتالي هذا تطور
لافت بالرغم من ان ما قاله لن يشير في اي
شكل من الاشكال الى اي دور امريكي في هذه
العمليه لكنها تكشف بان هناك توجه متشدد
من طرف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده في ما
يتعلق بايران والذي تعتبره الخطر الاول
الذي يتهددها في المنطقه جلال عبد القادر
ما المعطيات الايرانيه حول ما تقول بوست
جورنال بان ثلاث مسيرات اسرائيليه استهدفت
الموقع العسكري
جلال في الشكل هي تقريبا متطابقا ولكن في
المضمون مختلفه بشكل كبير اداه التنفيذ
هنا التي جرت في هجوم ليله امس هي ثلاث
طائرات من النوع الخفيفه المسيرات الخفيفه
او ما يصطلح على تسميتها
بالمينيدرونز الروايه الايرانيه تقول
بانها الحادث انطلق من داخل البلاد بمعنى
ان الطائرات المسيره خفيفه الوزن والملغمه
والتي توصف بانها طائرات انتحاريه
انطلقت من موقع قريب من هذا الموقع في
مدينه اصفهان وبانه الهجوم تم على هذا
الموقع بمعنى ان الهجوم تم باداء انطلقت
من الداخل
واستهدفت موقعا في الداخل ما يعني انه اذا
ما كانت اسرائيل تقف خلف هذا الهجوم هناك
ايادي داخل ايران هناك منفذين على الارض
داخل ايران هما قاموا بذلك هل هؤلاء
ايرانيون ام ماذا هذا سؤال غايه في
الاهميه
ثانيه همم الموقع المستهدف همم جلال نعلم
تماما بانه ليس المره الاولى الذي يتم
استهدافه هذا المجمع العسكري في اصفهان
قبل اربع سنوات همم ذات المكان ذات الاداه
بذات المضمون تقريبا تعرض الى دربكه هذه
بطائره واحده في ذلك التوقيت ولكن ايران
لم تعلن عن ذلك رسميه في ذلك التوقيت ولم
تقدم اي تفاصيل هذا موقع ربما مطلوب
استهدافه بالمعنى همم ربما الاسرائيلي
صحيح لانه يشكل ربما موقع مهم عندما نتحدث
عن الصواريخ البالستيه في ايران صحيح ولكن
الروايه الايرانيه تقول ثلاث مسيرات
المضادات الارضيه اصابت واحده في الجو
وعطلتها بالكامل واصابت اخرى اسقطتها على
الارض بينما الثالثه من ان تقع في داخل
المجمع العسكري ولكن روايه وزاره الدفاع
هنا في ايران بانه لا ضحى يا بشريه من هذا
الهجوم وبان الخسائر اقتصرت على تضرر مادي
تحديدا في احد الاسقف التابعه الانجارات
داخل هذا المجمع العسكري ذلك جلال يمكن ان
نقوله هناك سياق اقليمي متشنج جدا في
العلاقه بين طهران وا اسرائيل هذا صحيح
ولكن هذا الموقع مستهدف سابقا يمكن ان
نقول بان الروايه الايرانيه حتى الان
رسميا ايران لم توجه اصابع الاتهام لي
اسرائيل ولا لغيرها واكتفت وزاره الدفاع
بانها وصفت الحادث بانه غير موفق وبانه
فاشل وبان ما يجري داخل هذا ال- هذه
المنشاه العسكريه سيبقى همم قائما وبانه
لم يتضرر ولم يعطل لذلك يمكن ان نقول بانه
من حيث الشكل كل الكلام الذي جاء في
الصحيفه الامريكيه
يتطابق هنا مع الروايه ولكن من حيث
المضمون لدينا روايه ايرانيه مختلفه كليا
جلال
تتحدث عنه الصحافه الامريكيه وتحديدا هذه
الصحيحه يس كرام محمد اشار بحسب الصحيفه
لانه لا تعليق من الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن
كيف نفهم هذا التطور النوعي خصوصا بانه
ياتي مع عوده نتنياهو الى الحكم وهذه
الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه
السياسه الاسرائيليه تجاه ايران لم تتغير
تقريبا في السنوات الماضيه حتى عندما
تغيرت الحكومات في اعتبار التهديد
الايراني وتحديدا تهديد المشروع النووي
الايراني كتهديد وجودي على اسرائيل
الرسميه سواء كان ذلك على المستوى السياسي
والعسكري التزمت الصمت هي لهذه الانباء
وكل ما تتورده وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
هو ياتي بما تنشره الوسائل الاجنبيه او
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه تحديدا في هذا
السياق لكن دعنا نشير هنا الى ان اسرائيل
تتعمد الصمت كي لا تتيح للطرف الاخر اي
مبرر او تعطيه ايا مبرر للرد على هذه
الهجمات اذا كانت اسرائيل ستقول انا الذي
وجهته هذه الضربه في عمليه تعطي الطرف
الاخر المبرر للقيام بهجوم مضاد سواء كان
ذلك من ايران او سواء كان ذلك من جبهات
الاخرى كجه سوريا مثلا لذلك هي تلتزم
الصمت
ولك لكن من ناحيه اخرى ونحن سنرى ذلك في
الايام القليله المقبره سوف نرى بان وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه ووسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه سوف تكون زاخره بتفاصيل التفاصيل
حول ما جرى ليله امس في اصفهان ذلك ان
اسرائيل تتعمد على لسان مسؤولين عسكريين
بدون اسم ان تعطي التفاصيل الدقيقه لمثل
هذه العمليات وسبق ان راينا ذلك في مرات
سابقه هذا ليست المره الاولى التي تنسب
لاسرائيل فيها هجمات في داخل ايران كانت
هناك هجمات استهدفت اجهزه الطرد المركزيه
والشركات الكهرباء وسفن ايرانيه وغيرها من
الهجمات السيبرانيه وكانت اسرائيل دائما
تعطي تلتزم الصمت همم وسائل اعلامها لا
تتحدث عن ذلك لكن نرى بان وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه كانت تتحدث بالتفاصيل حتى انها
كانت تصل الى حد انها تريد ان تقول او
تعلن عن الرقم التسلسلي حتى للصاروخ الذي
ضرب المنشئه هذه همم بالمجمل العام
اسرائيل كانت بالفعل هي من وراء هذه
الضربه وهي ربما تكون المعنيه في ذلك هي
تريد ان تقول بانها ربما تنتقل الى مرحله
جديده اكثر تطورا الان لاسيما مع فشل
المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه وهي تريد همم ان
تقول بان المرحله الان هي مرحله التخطيط
ربما لها جماعه منسقه مع الاداره
الامريكيه وخير دليل على ذلك جلال ما همم
شهيدناه في الاسبوع الماضي من مناورات
وصفت بانها الاكبر والاوسع والاكثر جديه
التي شاركت فيها القياده المركزيه للجيش
الامريكي مع الجيش الاسرائيلي هنا في
صحراء النقب وفي شرق المتوسط والتي حاكت
بشكل واضح وصريح من خلال البيانات
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه بانها حاكت هجوما
يستهدف المنشات النوويه الايراني شكرا
لشبكات مراسلنا الياس في القدس محمد في
واشنطن وعبد القادر في طهران